at the time of this video's writing the
scp foundation currently contains well
over 6 000 items this organization
really gets around from making deals
with deities to containing horrors
capable of ending the world in a
heartbeat so it's hard to think of this
secret group ever having humble
beginnings but everyone and everything
has to start somewhere right and would
you believe that one of the most
powerful groups in the world all started
with a little sheaf of papers of course
that's if this particular iteration of
scp-001
is to be believed that's right we once
again return to scp-001
the gift that keeps on taking
it is a heavily contested spot currently
held by over 30 different contradictory
anomalies and counting their natures
vary from things that started the
foundation to things more than capable
of ending it along with the rest of the
world and everything in between the
scarlet king the gate guardian and the
ever eccentric dr wondertainment all
exist under this banner but today we
want to talk about a little stack of
paper
bound by a single staple in the top left
corner who would have guessed that
something this simple would not only be
pivotal in the creation of the scp
foundation as we know it today but could
also be one of the most dangerous items
ever discovered
we realize this is a lot to take in
keeping with the scp-001 spirit let's
take it all the way back to the
beginning to the fine oak desk of the
late
um
oh
we don't have a name shame
let's just call him the first
administrator he's the head honcho of
the precursor to the foundation as we
know it today a rinky dink little
organization with the thankless task of
keeping the paranormal under wraps we're
talking a long long time ago here no
lanky freaks who kill everybody who sees
their face no gloopy sadists who can
walk through walls no giant unkillable
reptiles with major anger issues this
organization let's call them the
precursors was dealing with the real
small fries paranoiacs reporting ghost
sightings in their garden sheds old
ladies finding the face of jesus in a
piece of toast abnormally large and
strangely shaped potato chips okay maybe
not that small time but you get the idea
truly exceptional anomalies were few and
far between until the sheaf of papers
landed on the dearly deceased
administrator's desk he didn't even know
how exactly the papers got there but
given the number of mostly junk files
that passed his desk every day he wasn't
in the business of questioning the words
confidential report on special items
classified were printed on the front
this made it more interesting than 90 of
the files he read on a daily basis
already so he turned the first page and
began to read it was much stranger than
the usual paranormal reports that the
precursor foundation processed no late
night whaling or rattling chains instead
it was a surprisingly sterile report
about a bizarre and frightening anomaly
a large fleshy tumor-like object fixed
to a set of metal stairs inside the
object is a seemingly normal living room
but on closer inspection all the
furniture is made out of living human
tissue and flesh anyone who steps inside
is transformed into more nightmarish
living furniture the administrator gave
a nervous chuckle it was disturbing sure
but stephen king wrote about disturbing
things all the time and that didn't mean
that the foundation needed to be on the
lookout for an evil clown well until
scp-993 the sinister bobble the clown
would enter the foundation's radar a few
years later that's a video for another
time the administrator put the file into
his incredibly disorganized filing
cabinet and prepared to go home and
drink bourbon until he fell asleep
that's exactly when his office phone
began to ring when the administrator
picked up the phone he heard the excited
voice of one of his field agents telling
him they just scored the find of the
century a giant sphere made from living
flesh with a room inside finally an
honest-to-god terrifying paranormal
anomaly he could hardly believe what he
was hearing he needed to grab and reread
the file just to make sure he wasn't
going insane where exactly did he put it
he scrambled through the filing cabinet
tossing aside the files on shed ghosts
and burnt toast jesuses until he found
the file marked confidential report on
special items classified however when he
opened the file there was nothing about
the giant fleshy room in there it must
have been a completely different file
that he'd somehow missed before because
this one was about something known as
the biological motherboard the document
detailed pretty much exactly what the
name suggested a large and incredibly
complex motherboard made out of
biological material like keratin and
chitin while the motherboard would
remain inactive if kept warm if its
environment ever fell below 35 degrees
it would begin to expand integrating
nearby material into its mass and
attempting to copy the structure of any
biological matter it comes into contact
with an interesting and frightening
prospect but not what he was looking for
he threw this new file down onto his
desk and continued to work through his
chaotic filing cabinet like a madman
searching for the file on that
frightening fleshy room that his
subordinates had seemingly actually
discovered but not long after that he
received another phone call from a
completely different field agent this
time the agent was giddily telling the
administrator about a new discovery a
huge computer motherboard seemingly made
out of entirely organic material the
administrator was floored he hung up the
phone and slowly turned back to the file
now laying on his desk those words on
the cover confidential report on special
items classified seemed almost mocking
now had all these incredible
supernatural anomalies been reported
before and just lost in his awful filing
cabinet was he one of the most
incompetent team leaders who'd ever
walked the earth just what exactly was
going on here he sat back down at his
desk now fantasizing about the tumblr of
bourbon more than ever and opened the
file again hoping to read up a little
more on the impossible motherboard that
his personnel had just discovered but
there was nothing about the biological
motherboard on these pages instead it
described a large door inside a factory
and the 12 rusty keys capable of opening
it each of these keys would open the
doorway but the key used would affect
the reality waiting for them on the
other side only the 7th and 12th keys
were safe opening the door with any of
the others would lead to a horrible
death for anyone brave or foolish enough
to walk through
several days later an anomaly matching
that exact description was discovered
and contained by the foundation all of
this had been an unprecedented
escalation of anomalous stakes suddenly
two crucial facts clicked into place for
the administrator firstly this file was
an anomalous supernatural artifact of
its own secondly the reason it was never
the same thing was that this strange
sheaf of papers had a very specific
purpose to act as a kind of oracle an
advanced warning system of the next
anomaly that would appear and fall into
their grasp giving them all the
knowledge and tools they needed to
safely lock these things away the whole
thing had been timed perfectly what a
miracle that this immensely useful item
would appear in his office just as the
anomalies would start to come in thick
and fast it would facilitate their
mission in the coming struggles to
secure contain and protect the world's
anomalies hmm
there's a certain ring to that isn't
there they were finding enough anomalies
to start classifying them numerically
starting with the sheaf of papers
themselves as scp-001
with another turn of the page the
administrator discovered a file on a
magical key that can open any lock not
long after that exact key was discovered
and brought in before being designated
scp-005
little by little as more real anomalies
came in the organization was able to
expand and bring in more personnel as
well as bring in more sources of funding
and opening new sites the rate this
organization was expanding they couldn't
even leave management up to one person
anymore they needed to form a whole
council to take over management n05
council if you will and it just so
happened that just after that the sheaf
of papers revealed a mythical spring
that could provide eternal health and
vitality for anyone who drinks from it
what a perfect way to keep your
management safe in a job dealing with
dangerous supernatural entities and
things only got stranger and more
fascinating from there after that came a
man with a miniature version of the
planet earth inside his abdomen soon
known as
scp-007 next came a horrifying virus
that kills and reanimates its victims
into flesh-eating zombies only capable
of being destroyed with sufficient
trauma to the head dubbed
scp-008 after containment another turn
of the page and not long after a
frightening red ice was discovered in
alaska this mysterious substance breaks
the laws of physics and also has the
potential to break all life on earth it
can infect water supplies and when a
hapless life form happens to drink this
water their organs crystallize from the
inside this became
scp-009 another turn of the page and
this new scp foundation found a
collection of six metal collars created
for human size necks when these collars
are placed around the necks of a victim
the person holding a corresponding
controller has utter domination over
their every action it carried on like
that hundreds of anomalies and then
thousands years passed the staff changed
the old guard stepped down or died every
time the sheaf of papers were opened new
astonishing premonitions of anomaly soon
to be discovered slipped through there
were plague doctors who could kill with
a touch a giant angel with bladed wings
a sea snail that believed he was an
english lord a sculpture that would kill
anyone that dared to stop looking at it
a nightmarish fusion of a giant bovine
heart and a scorpion capable of setting
things on fire with its venom whatever
would the scp foundation have done
without the advanced warning system
provided by the sheaf of papers whatever
it predicted would inevitably be the
next thing foundation field agents would
find it seems like one of the few
unambiguously good scp-001 entries out
there right well not quite if we have
any scientists in the audience they've
no doubt been gritting their teeth and
pulling their hair out in frustration
allow us to introduce you to a little
phrase that the latest iteration of the
o5 council is very interested in when it
comes to the sheaf of papers direction
of causality
this whole time we in the earlier
foundation administrators believe that
the emergence of the new anomalies led
to changes in
scp-001 but this current administration
has quite the opposite question what if
the changes in
scp-001 were actually causing the
emergence of new anomalies what if every
time the prior administration opened up
the sheaf of papers to take a look at
the next anomaly before giving
themselves a pat on the back for being
so well prepared they were actually
unleashing that very anomaly could it be
that what had seemed like the most
helpful item of the bunch was actually
the most dangerous of them all releasing
new anomaly after new anomaly blighting
the world with countless horrors that
probably leaves you with one question so
which is correct is it a method of
seeing the future or manipulating it and
our answer is a strong
we don't know but frankly the current
leadership of the scp foundation sees no
merit in taking that risk that's why the
chief of papers has been given the keter
class designation and is kept under
extensive and severe containment methods
forbidding any future research into the
true nature of its anomalous abilities
seems a little severe sure but better
safe than sorry right now go check out
scp-001
which is the real zero zero one and
scp-001 oroboro cycle the full story
compilation for more of the fascinating
and endless mystery of scp-001